welcome to this video on playing
amarcord I'm abroad from Austrian right
yes always glad to get something right
okay the goon felt okay I'm always
tempted I've had this strange h4 line
let's try that again c5 wow what then
it's very hard to believe giving away to
two pawns like that yeah okay let's um
let's trade and see yeah he probably
gets e5 back with night a six and c5
it's very difficult to to keep them to
keep the pawn but that should be able to
learn to keep one extra pawn maybe
Bishop e3 evening okay let's try that
night a six yeah i can go Bishop before
here why not well let's say I'm
protecting this may be nice g4 but I
want to be ready for nye g-force I go
Bishop g4 I can't I can't keep it for a
moment
okay III yeah well I need to protect the
phone yeah maybe maybe looks the age
until all get it back but the store
looks like quite a comfortable position
let's consider rook c8 I can play
annoying moves like 95 ok just this one
yeah if I castle long he might play
Knight g4 this could be better show some
maybe 92 is better answered with this or
attended to um yeah the check here are
still a check here yeah of course he's
got some development some it's not like
he's got no compensation loser this is
clear yeah night see to work hmm 92 as
soon as a problem but what if I if I
give up the exchange and play for for
the space and this could be an idea or
just king of one I mean I don't really
believe it on light c2 just King f1 he
can take d 4 e takes d4 and really two
pawns hmm check I don't believe that
this is enough I can also take with the
night which is not completely crazy
night XD for we are maybe even that one
attending to take on f5
yeah it's not it's not easy to play
because you have such a strange piece
coordination is black but it's um of
course a good position so okay let's
take it and how to how to continue now
this is one seat tube is very vulnerable
if I go F or am I not just winning this
piece black resigned yeah I am winning
the piece did I overlooked that before
actually no I was just like first and
right here I am I played the planet
correctly yeah I cannot believe in indy
for this this is really a really a bit
much giving up two pawns and it's not
that I'm so far behind the development
maybe he needs to do something else
instead of night 86 might be there's
some someone tough tough defense yeah
plus two should be six then we should
buy five you probably cannot cannot
justify all this this is just giving
away this piece yeah I don't know what
what is the best line against them h
form I I always thought that if
everything else fails you can always
place your six and make this look this
move look a bit strange in the Slav but
it's it's a way to get off them the
beaten tracks are only four wide some
edge for the new phone you can try if
you want to be creative ollie okay
thanks for watching